efectiva
bajo una perspectiva canales puedo decir
que en las calles de kabul mucha gente
es bastante escéptica sobre las promesas
que los talibanes han estado haciendo
durante las últimas semanas dirigidas
sobre todo a la comunidad internacional
in plain we could 6 foto past weeks
como sabrán afganistán está muy cerca de
un colapso económico y es extremadamente
dependiente de los miles de millones de
dólares que podrían llegar al país
provenientes de la comunidad
internacional
valdés busquets com
from the international community show
crimen estuviese en the afghan tipo de
bilibid very much maybe
así que queda mucho por ver los afganos
no tienen demasiada fe quizás porque
siguen traumatizados por el periodo de
reinado del terror de los talibanes
entre 1996 y 2001
sin embargo lo que es muy importante hoy
viernes que aquí es como un domingo es
que las calles están bastante vacías así
que podríamos esperar el anuncio de este
nuevo gobierno inclusivo o no para el
final del día después de la gran oración
trier
[Música]
y dónde están
las cuestiones que tenemos que entender
que los comandos talibanes se están
moviendo rápido para la comunidad
internacional pero también para los
afganos porque la gente en afganistán y
especialmente en la capital kabul no es
la misma que en 1996 han pasado 20 años
de emancipación alfabetización y podemos
percibir que no están demasiado
contentos al dirigirse hacia un futuro
incierto hay muchas preguntas sin
respuestas pero la primera respuesta
debería hacer dinero en efectivo
podemos ver mucha gente haciendo colas
para obtener unos cuantos dólares un
poco de dinero principalmente para la
comida en ciudades recién hace un
manifesto dubai food administration's
las instituciones las administraciones
están todas cerradas los talibanes lo
saben esta es la razón por la que
necesitan avanzar a corto plazo y
presentar su nuevo gobierno del nuevo
emirato islámico de afganistán los días
new islámica